The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
So we are still in a
discussion of atoms
in external magnetic fields.
And we are working our way
up from simple static fields
to time dependent fields.
Last week and the
week before, we
covered external magnetic
fields, Zeeman shifts,
different coupling limits,
strong field, and weak field.
Last class on Friday,
we talked about what
happens when you put atoms
into DC electric fields.
So what we did was simple.
Lowest order, which means
in this case, second order
perturbation theory.
And we derived an
explicit expression
for the polarizability, alpha.
And this polarizability
tells us how energy levels
are shifted quadratically
with the electric field.
I put some emphasis
in talking about what
is inside perturbation theory
and identified with you that,
yes, if you have
an electric field,
we have electrostatic energy.
But in order to
polarize the atoms,
we have to create
an internal energy.
In a concrete example,
if we have an s state,
we have to mix a p state
to create a dipole moment.
And this costs energy.
Exactly in the same way
as when you have a spring
and pull on the
spring with gravity,
you gain gravitational energy.
But you have two pay
exactly half of it
to create internal
energy in your spring.
And this is actually the
reason for this factor of 1/2
as we discussed in great length.
Question is do you have any
questions about that part?
Because we want to
go to the next level.
Perturbation theory?
DC polorizability?
So anyway, the menu
for today is we
have done perturbation theory
here for weak electric fields.
But the question came already
up in class, is it really valid?
Or for what regime
is it invalid?
So today I want to
talk to you briefly
what happens when we go
beyond perturbation theory.
When we go beyond the
quadratic Stark effect.
And that leads us
to a discussion
on stability of atoms in
strong electric field and field
ionization.
I like to sort of feature
it because it allows
me to tell you something
about the peculiar properties
of Rydberg atoms.
And also the
ionization of Rydberg
atoms through electric field.
This is how people in our
field create cold plasmas.
And it's also a way to do a very
sensitive detection of atoms.
So what I'm telling you today
is interesting for its own sake,
but also because it's an
important tool for manipulating
atoms, creating plasmas,
or sensitive detection.
So this will probably only
take 10 or 20 minutes.
And then we want to go
form DC electric fields
to AC electric fields.
So we then discuss
the AC polarizability.
And, well, that will take
us from perturbation theory
in a time independent way what
we have done now for DC fields
to time dependent
perturbation theory.
So all the topics are
rather basic aspects
of quantum physics.
But as usual, I try to give
you some special perspectives
from the atomic physics side.
So in perturbation theory, we
have a mixture of other states.
And this said mixture is
done with the matrix element.
And in perturbation
theory, we always
have an energy denominator.
Intermediate state
to ground state.
And if the electric field
is smaller than this value,
then we have mixture of other
states into the ground state.
So usually when we estimate
the validity of perturbation
theory, we look
for the state which
is closest to the ground state.
For which the energy
denominator is smallest.
So therefore, i here is the
nearest state, but, and this
is important, of
opposite parity.
Otherwise, because of the
parity selection rule,
the matrix element would
be 0 and electric field
does nothing.
I made a comment on Friday,
but let me do it again.
That, of course, means that
when we apply electric field
to our favorite
atoms, we don't have
to worry about the
other hyperfine states.
The other hyperfine states have
the same spatial wave function.
Have the same parity.
So we are really here talking
about the first excited state.
And a concrete example
for those of you
who work with alkalis
with an s ground
state, the relevant
energy scale here
is the excitation energy
to the first p state.
So let's just estimate it
for a single electron atom.
And well, this is a
hydrogenic estimate.
The excitation energy to
the first excited state.
1s to 2p is about 1 Rydberg.
And the Rydberg is
nothing, or Hartree,
and that's nothing else
than e square over a0.
It's electric potential
of two charges separated
by Bohr radius.
And if we estimate
that the matrix element
for strong transition is on
the order of the Bohr radius,
there are no other length
scales in the problem,
we find that the value for the
electric field in atomic units
is the charge divided by
the Bohr radius squared.
And this is really high.
It is on the order of 5 times
10 to the 9 volt per centimeter.
And this is 1,000 times
larger than laboratory
electric fields.
Those fields would just create
sparking along the electrodes.
You cannot apply such
high electric fields
in a laboratory.
So, therefore, nothing
to worry about.
If you have ground state
atoms, the Stark effect
in perturbation theory
is all you need.
Actually, to be a little
bit more precise when
I used the Rydberg and a0, I
made a little bit overestimate.
So that the typically the
critical electric field
which would cause a breakdown
of perturbation theory
for the ground
state is around 10
to the 9 volt per centimeter.
OK, so we are safe when we
talk about ground states.
But once we got to the excited
state, we have degeneracy.
p states have a
three fold degeneracy
and they are states
with opposite parity.
So we can't have mixing there.
And actually as we will
see for excited states,
we have already a breakdown
of perturbation theory
at very, very small
electric field.
So let us discuss
hydrogenic orbits
with principal
quantum number, n.
And if you estimate what is
the size of the matrix element?
Well, it's not just a0.
There is a scaling with
n which is n square.
The matrix element in higher
and higher excited state scales
with n square.
Well, how does the
energy separation scale?
Well, let's not
discuss hydrogen here.
Because in hydrogen, energy
levels are degenerate.
And we would immediately
get a breakdown
of perturbation theory.
Let's rather formulate
it for general atoms.
And we had this nice discussion
about the quantum defect.
So if we compare the energy of
two l states, they scale as 1
over n square.
But for different l states, we
have different quantum defects.
Delta l plus 1.
And here we have delta l.
So, therefore, doing
an expansion in m
which we assume to be large, we
find that the energy difference
is proportional to the
difference between the quantum
defects for the
two states we want
to mix with the electric field.
And then again, the scaling with
the principal quantum number
is n cube.
So, therefore, we find
for the critical field
using the criterion
I mentioned above.
We take the energy splitting.
The energy the denominator which
appears in perturbation theory.
We divide by the value
of the matrix element.
Well, we had the Rydberg
constant or two times
the Rydberg constant is nothing
else than b squared over a0.
The matrix element
was 1 over a0.
And then we have the difference
between quantum defects.
And now-- and this makes
it really so dramatic.
We had an n square scaling
of the matrix element.
And we have an into the minus 3
scaling of energy differences.
So that means the critical
field scales by n to the 5.
Go to an excited state
with n equals 10.
And the breakdown of
perturbation theory
happens 100,000 times earlier.
So some of the scaling
in atomic physics
is very, very
dramatic when you go
to more highly excited state.
If you threw in that quantum
defects become very small,
once you go beyond
s and p states.
The higher states just don't
penetrate into the nucleus.
So if l is larger than 2, if
you have more complicated atoms,
you may add the angular
momentum of the core here.
But so if you put n to the 5
scaling and the small quantum
defect together, you find
that critical electric fields
are smaller than one
volt per centimeter
already for principal
quantum numbers as low as 7.
So that means bring a 1.5 volt
battery close to your atom
and you drive it crazy.
You drive it out of
perturbation theory.
So what we have
is the following.
We have, of course,
the structure
of atoms in excited field.
Here is the electric field.
And let me just
pick three n values.
18, 19, 20.
And now the
structure, of course,
is that by the
criterion I actually
gave you was the criterion for
the application of perturbation
theory.
If the energy levels are
smaller than the matrix element,
you have to rediagonalize
between those levels.
And that gives you then not a
quadratic, but a linear effect.
So, therefore, the
structure is here
that you have a region where
you have strong l mixing.
So you have to use
degenerate perturbation
theory for the
different l states.
But the many folds in n, the
principle quantum number,
are still well separated.
But then, eventually,
when you go further,
you have a region which
is called n mixing.
So now the electric
field is really
completely rediagonalizing your
states with different quantum
numbers, n.
So the result of
this discussion is
that highly excited
states of atoms
behave very differently
from ground state atoms.
And n to the 5 scaling
is sensitivity to volt
per centimeter.
Level mixing all over the place.
And that's why for those
highly excited states,
people have coined the word
Rydberg atoms or Rydberg
matter.
That means atoms with higher
principal quantum numbers.
And the study of Rydberg
atoms was pioneered, well,
the early pioneering work
by our own, Dan Kleppner.
And then Herbert
Walther in Munich
who happened to be
my Ph.D. Advisor.
And finally, Serge
Haroche, who was recognized
with the last Nobel Prize
together with Dave Wineland.
So this is not just theory.
What I am showing to
you here is spectroscopy
done at MIT by Dan Kleppner.
So what is done here is
from the ground state,
they excite to an excited state.
And whenever you hit an excited
state, you see a signal.
Let's focus on the upper part.
So if at a given electric
field, you scan the laser,
you get one of those traces.
You find peaks, peaks, peaks.
And those peaks correspond to
the different and many folds
with strong Stark mixing.
And eventually when you go
to somewhat higher field,
you have states
all over the place.
And this is the regime where
you have done n mixing.
So in the '70s and
'80s, there was really,
those experiments obtained
a clear understanding
and description
of atoms in, well,
I would say high
electric fields.
But the fields were not so high.
It was just the atoms were
very sensitive that already
is at lower electric
fields, they
reached what is regarded
as the high-field limit.
Now the question is
when we recorded signal,
suddenly the traces stop.
And that means the electric
field is now so high
that the atom no longer
has a stable state.
The electric field is so
high that it literally rips
the electron away from the atom.
And if you go to higher
states, the electric field
where this happens is lower.
This is the process
of field ionization
and that's what we
want to discuss next.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Um, for what atoms?
PROFESSOR: Those studies were
actually done for lithium.
It's actually peculiar.
Dan Kleppner really
liked hydrogen.
Dan Kleppner is the
person who tried
to do almost all
experiments with hydrogen.
The famous BEC experiment.
He also had the
Rydberg experiment
which was just in building 26
where Vladan Vuletic teaches
now, his labs.
This is where
spectroscopy of hydrogen
were done with the
goal of a precision
measurement of the
Rydberg constant.
So we excited hydrogen to
some of those high levels.
But as probably
the experts know,
the hydrogen atom is the
hardest atom to work with.
Because you need
[INAUDIBLE] and alpha.
You have this huge gap to
the first excited state.
And that's why if
you can get away,
you try to work
with other atoms.
And in those
experiments, those people
worked with the lithium atom.
So the lithium atom
has a quantum defect
which will actually contrast
to hydrogen where the quantum
defect is 0.
And this will actually
be very, very important
for field ionization as
I want to discuss now.
Other questions?
OK, so at a given electric
field, states, so to speak,
just disappear.
They're no longer stable.
And this is the process which
is called field ionization.
So the phenomenon is
that sufficiently strong
electric fields ionize the atom.
And whenever there
is a simple model
and I can give you an analytic
answer, I try to do that.
Because I feel a
lot of our intuition
is shaped by understanding
simple models.
And the simplest model
for field ionization
is just the classical
model by calculating
what is the settle point
in the combined potential.
The combined potential
of the nucleus
which is a Coulomb potential
and the external magnetic field.
So many features
of the experiment
can be understood by this
simple three line derivation.
So we have a potential.
One part of it is the
Coulomb potential.
And focusing on one
spatial direction here.
And then, in addition, we
apply an electric field.
And the electric field
creates a linear potential.
And if I take the sum of the
two, well, at large distances,
see, it's the electric
field which dominates.
Then the Coulomb
potential takes over.
So that's how it looks like.
So now we have the situation
if we would put in atoms
and we would look at
the energy eigenvalues.
At this point, this is
the maximum excited state
in the atom which
is still stable.
So what I want to derive
for you is what determines
the stability is simply
the settle point.
When the binding energy of
the excited state for which we
use the Rydberg
formula is not stronger
than the position
of the settle point,
the atom becomes unstable it
and becomes field ionized.
And we'll discuss
a little bit later
if this really
applies to real atoms.
The quick answer is for lithium
and all the other atoms,
it applies.
For hydrogen, it doesn't.
Because hydrogen has
too many symmetries.
Too many exact degeneracies.
OK, so the total potential
is the Coulomb potential
plus the electric potential.
What we need is the position
of the settle point.
Where we have a
maximum in this one.
This is a one dimensional cut.
And this one dimensional cut
has a maximum at this position.
And by taking the derivative
of the total potential,
you immediately find
this to be of that value.
And now what we are
calculating next
is what is the potential
energy at this point.
And, well, this is just copy
from the notes, e to the 3/2.
And now what we want
to do is we want
to postulate that
for field ionization,
this should be able to the
binding energy of the electron.
Which is nothing
else than the Rydberg
constant divided by n square.
OK, now here, we
have the square root
of the electric field
from this calculation.
So that means the critical
electric field will scale as 1
over n to the 4.
And this is a
famous scaling which
can be found in many textbooks.
That the critical electric
field for ionization equals,
and now, that's the
beauty of atomic units,
it is 1/16, n to the 4.
Beautiful formula derived from
the settle point criteria.
Of course, what I mean here is,
and if you do the derivation,
it's in atomic units.
Which means in units
of the atomic unit
of the electric field which is
e over the Bohr radius squared.
So it's a simple model.
It's an analytic result.
The question is is it valid?
Does it make any sense?
And the answer is yes, but in
a quantum mechanical problem,
you would actually solve
Schroedinger's equation,
such a potential.
But then, the onset
of field ionization
comes when tunnelling becomes
possible for this barrier.
But it is the
nature of tunnelling
that if you're a little bit too
low, tunneling is negligible.
You may have ionization rates
of 1 per millisecond or so.
And if you just go
a little bit closer,
it becomes exponentially larger.
So, therefore, this scaling
is very, very accurate.
Because the transition where
you go from weak tunneling,
to strong tunneling, to
spilling over the barrier,
it's a very narrow range
of electric fields.
But, yes, people have looked
at it in great details
and have calculated
corrections due to tunneling.
So these are quantum corrections
to the classical threshold
which I just calculated.
But now in hydrogen, a lot of
n, l mixing matrix elements,
matrix elements due
to the electric field
between an l states vanish.
Hydrogen is just too
pure, too precise.
There is actually
parabolic quantum numbers
where you can
exactly diagonalize
hydrogen electric fields.
And you find some stable
states which do not decay.
And they are above the
classical threshold
we have just calculated.
So as Dan Kleppner would have
said, the simplest of all atoms
is the most complicated when
it comes to field ionization.
Because it has a
lot of stable states
above the classical barrier.
So you can sort of
envision that there
will be orbits which are
just confined to this region.
And the electron never
samples the settle point.
And if you look at it
this diagram on the wiki,
these are actually
calculations for hydrogen
which include ionization rates.
You will find that
the states which
are the ones which
go down, which
are on the downhill side
of the electric field,
you see always here marked
an onset for ionization.
And then you see
a rapid increase
in the ionization rate.
But you also see
those hydrogenic state
which go upward in energy
and they refuse to ionize.
Because of the symmetry
of parabolic coordinates
and the things I've mentioned.
Anyway, it's too especially
to spend more time here
in class on it, but I just
think you should at least know
qualitatively what is
different for hydrogen.
OK, so that's what
I wanted to tell you
about high electric fields and
field ionization in principle.
Let me now briefly mention
important applications
of field ionization.
One is close to 100% detection
efficiency for atoms.
If you want to
detect single atoms,
for instance, you'll
have a krypton sample
and you want to find a
rare isotope of krypton
for dating the material.
You need an extremely
high sensitivity
and you may just have a few
single atoms in the sample.
One way to do it would be
that you excite the atom maybe
through an intermediate
state, to Rydberg state.
And then by just applying
a few volt per centimeter,
you get an ion.
And ions can be counted
by particle detectors.
You can accelerate the ion,
smash it into a surface
and count the particles with
close to 100% efficiency.
And this is one of the most
sensitive detection schemes.
I remember in the
aftermath of Chernobyl,
there was an interest
in detection schemes
for radioactive strontium.
And on the wiki, I
give you a reference
where some people developed
this resonance ionization
spectroscopy for
some atomic isotopes.
Which unfortunately
appeared more frequently
after the Chernobyl disaster.
And they developed
a method based
on excitation to Rydberg states.
Which was more sensitive
than other methods.
You may ask why don't you
ionize it with a laser?
Well, the fact is, you can
photoionize it with a laser.
It's another alternative, but
it takes much more laser power.
Because if you excite
into the continuum,
the matrix element
is much smaller.
And often, if you want to have
100% ionization probability
to go into the continuum, you
need such high laser power
that you may get some background
of resonant ionization
of other elements and such.
So Rydberg atoms is really
the smart way to go.
You go to an almost bound to
an almost unbound electron.
And then it's just
the electric field
which causes the final
act of ionization.
I also want to briefly mention
that the famous experiments
on Rydberg atoms by
Herbert Walther and Serge
Haroche and collaborators
would not have been possible
without field ionization.
I give you this one
reference, but I'm
sure you'll find more
in the actually very,
very nicely written Nobel
lecture of Serge Haroche.
I just read it a few
weeks ago and it's
a delight to read how
he exposes the field.
So they did QED experiments by
having microwave transitions
between atoms in two
highly excited states.
Let's say with principal
quantum number 50 and 51.
So that's now conveniently
in the microwave regime.
Then those atoms are
passed through a cavity.
And in this cavity, single atoms
interact with single photons.
And they have done beautiful
quantum non-demolition
experiments of single photons.
I mean that's really wonderful,
state of the art experiments.
Back to Rydberg atoms
and field ionization.
Eventually, the read
out of those experiments
was you prepare atoms
in the state 50 or 51.
And afterwards, if they have
absorbed or emitted a photon,
they should be in
a different state.
So you were interested in a very
high detection efficiency which
could distinguish
between 50 and 51.
And of course there is a
way to distinguish that.
And this is because
of n to the 4.
You first apply
an electric field
which can only field ionized 51.
And then you allow
the atoms to propagate
into a slightly
higher electric field.
And then the 50s are ionized.
So the standard
experiment is that you
pass those atoms between
two field plates.
And by putting an angle
between them that indicates
the voltage is increasing.
And then you have
two little holes.
You have some channel-drawn
particle detectors.
And the first detector
will detect the 51s
and the second detector will
detect the lower lying states.
So you can detect every
atom with high probability,
but also in a state
selective way.
So this way of doing state
selective field ionization
based on the discussion
we had earlier, this
is sort of the method of
choice for experiments
involving Rydberg atoms.
Any questions about atoms
in the electric fields?
Well, then.
Frequently we add
time dependence.
So what we should
do next is atoms
in oscillating electric fields.
It's also a good way to
review what we have done.
Because the first
thing to do now
is we calculate the
polarizability for AC fields.
We calculate the
AC Stark effect.
And, of course, if in the AC
Stark effect we said omega 2, 0
will retrieve the
DC Stark effect.
So in a way, what I'm
doing for you now is
I'm using time dependent
perturbation theory
to obtain a new result.
But it will reproduce
the result of time
independent perturbation theory
which we have just discussed.
All right, so atoms in
oscillating electric fields.
Of course the next
step is, and this
is where we are
working towards, we
will in the next few lectures
starting on Wednesday.
Well, then there is Spring
Break, but in the next lectures
develop a deep
understanding what
happens when atoms
interact with light.
And oscillating electric
fields is already
pretty close to light.
And I want to
actually also show you
that we capture already a
lot of the phenomena which
happen with light except
for a full understanding
of spontaneous emission.
So we pretty much when we use
an oscillating electric field,
we allow the atom to
interact with just one
mode of the
electromagnetic field.
Which is filled with
a coherent state.
And this is so classical
that we don't even
need field quantization.
We just use a classical
electric field.
And this already gives us the
interaction of atoms with light
except for spontaneous
emission which
involves all the other modes.
So that's what we do later.
But today, we just do the
same classical description
of an atom in an
oscillating electric field.
And this is the theory
of the AC Stark effect.
So all we do is application
of time dependent perturbation
theory.
So our electric field
is now time dependent.
It has a value epsilon,
polarization e hat,
and it oscillates.
Our perturbation
Hamiltonian is exactly
the same dipole Hamiltonian
we had before for the DC Stark
effect.
But now it's a
time dependent one.
And it will be useful to break
up the oscillating term in e
to the i omega, t and e
to the minus i omega t.
I don't want to bore you with
perturbation theory in quantum
mechanics because you've
all seen it in 805 or 806.
I just want to
jump to the result.
You find more details
about it on the wiki.
But all you do is you
parametrize your wave function,
you expand it into
eigenstates with amplitude an.
And then you put it into
the Schroedinger equation
and assume that for
short times the atom
is in the ground state.
The amplitude of the
ground state is 1.
And the amplitude
of the excited state
is infinitesimal that you
can use the lowest order
perturbation.
This immediately gives
you the first order result
for the amplitude in
an excited state, k.
It only comes about because
your initial state, the ground
state, is coupled by the matrix
element to the excited state.
It's linear in the
applied electric field.
So what you do is you have
the Schroedinger equation
and you integrate it
from times 0 to time 1.
And since you have e
to the i omega, t and e
to the minus i omega t, you
get two time dependent terms.
e to the i.
So what appears now is we
have the frequencies omega
n of the excited state.
And now when we couple
the excited state, k,
to the ground
state, what appears
is the frequency
difference between the two.
That's pretty much
the excitation gap.
And we have a time dependent
oscillation at omega.
And then we have, of
course, the same term
where we flip the
sign from omega--
let me write that more clearly.
Where we flip the sign
from omega to minus omega.
So that's the second term.
By integrating an exponential
function with respect to time,
we get an energy and a frequency
denominator which is this one.
So this is really
just straight forward,
most basic plain
vanilla application
of perturbation theory.
The only thing I want to
discuss because it sometimes
confuses people is
that we integrate
from times 0 to the finite time.
And then you integrate,
you get contributions
from the upper
integration limit.
And from the lower
And this contribution at
the lower integration limit
is actually a transient.
It is at the frequency.
It doesn't depend on omega.
So it's a beat node between
the ground and excited state.
I could say at
frequency omega k,
but then it's together with the
ground state, it's omega kg.
And this is due to if you
switch on a perturbation,
it's like you suddenly
switch on the drive
of an harmonic oscillator.
And you have some ringing.
You have a transient at
the natural frequency
of the harmonic oscillator.
It has nothing to
do with the drive.
It's just a sudden onset.
It's transient and frequent
due to the sudden switch on.
So like any
transient, we haven't
included damping in here.
We don't have
spontaneous emission.
Everything is undamped.
But eventually, all
those transients
will damp out with time.
And as we should have known
also from the beginning,
when we drive a system, when
we switch on a perturbation,
just think about an
harmonic oscillator.
You have a response at the
harmonic oscillator frequency
which is always
transient in nature.
And then you have a response
at the dry frequency.
And we are
interested, of course,
only in the driven response
The driven response
is at frequency
plus minus omega.
That's how we drive it.
But now I have to
be careful since I'm
looking at the amplitude and I
factor out the time dependence
of the time dependence of
the wave function, the time
dependence of the eigenstates.
I'm now looking for drive
terms in this expression
for the amplitude which
are at frequency omega,
but modified by the ground.
Or the frequency of
the ground state.
But anyway, what I mean
is the relevant term
is the one which
depends on omega.
And in the following discussion,
I simply drop the minus 1
because it's a transient.
If you would switch on your
time dependent electric field
in a smoother way, this
term would disappear.
OK, let's now be specific.
Let's assume the electric field
points in the z direction.
For an isotropic medium,
the dipole moment,
the time dependent dipole
moment which we induce
is also pointing
in the z direction.
And so we want to calculate now
what is the dipole moment which
is created by the drive term?
By the driven electric Field
And for that, we simply
use the perturbation theory
we have just applied.
We take the ground state and
its first order correction.
And calculate the expectation
value of the dipole moment.
In the line at the top, we
have the first order correction
to the ground state
wave function.
And so we just plug it in.
And what we obtain
is result where
we have the matrix
elements squared.
Remember, we do first
order perturbation theory
which is one occurrence
of the matrix element,
but now we take a
second matrix element
because we're interested
in the dipole operator.
So this gives us now a sum
over matrix element squared.
We have e to the plus i omega
t and e to the minus i omega t.
This means we get 2 times the
real part of this expression.
And the time dependent
term is e to the i omega t.
And then we have the term
with plus and minus omega.
Yes.
And so, most
importantly, everything
is driven by the electric field.
We can now just to write
the result in an easier way,
we can use this result
with omega minus omega.
And the real part
and write that.
We can write that as
2 times omega k, g.
Omega k, g squared minus omega
squared, times cosine omega t,
times the electric field.
And now finally, we
have the matrix element.
We have integrated the e to the
i omega t function and such.
So what we have here now is the
time dependent electric field.
And what we have
here is the factor
by which we multiply
the electric field
to obtain the bipole moment.
And this is the
definition of the now
time dependent or frequency
dependent polarizability.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why are we only
getting the cosine and not
[INAUDIBLE]?
You only multiply by the other
terms to get the [INAUDIBLE]?
In terms of the cosine.
PROFESSOR: I haven't
done the math yesterday
when I prepared for the class.
I did it a while ago
when I wrote those notes,
but you know, one comment, I
know you don't want to hear it,
but it's a following.
This system has no
dissipation at all.
And when I drive
it, I will always
get a response which is
in phase with the drive.
It can be cosine omega t,
or minus cosine omega t.
You cannot get a
quadrature at this point.
So if you find I've made a
mistake, and you would say,
there is a sine, omega
term, I've made a mistake.
I know for physical reasons,
I cannot get a phase shift.
You only get a phase shift
in the response of a system
to drive when you
have dissipation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll have to talk with you.
PROFESSOR: But why
don't-- I mean,
I know the result is correct.
And this is just, I
hate to spend class time
in trying to figure out
if I've omitted one term.
AUDIENCE: The real part.
PROFESSOR: But the real part
what I've probably done is--
AUDIENCE: I think that's
probably what you did.
Yeah.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: I think
that's what I did.
So let me, therefore,
also say we have now
included the real part of it.
Yes.
OK, thank you.
OK, this part here
can actually--
that's how we often report.
And that's how you often
find in textbook the result,
the frequency dependence
of the AC polarizability.
But I like to rewrite it
now in a different way which
is identical.
And it shows now that there
are two contributions.
And I will discuss
them in a moment.
But those two contributions,
one has in the denominator,
let's assume we excite the
system close to resonance.
Omega is close to omega kg.
Then one term is
much, much closer.
It's to a near
resonant excitation.
And from our discussion
about rotating frames,
we have all of this near
resonant excitation corresponds
to a corotating term.
And the other one corresponds
to a counter rotating term.
We've not assumed any
rotating fields here,
but we find those terms with
the same mathematical signature.
And I will discuss
that little bit later.
But the physics is between the
corotating and counterrotating
term.
And it's the
corotating term which
is the term which [INAUDIBLE]
the so-called rotating
wave approximation.
I just want to identify
those two terms
and let's hold the thought for
until we have the discussion.
What I first want to say
is the limiting case.
We have not made any
assumptions about frequency.
When we let omega go to 0,
we obtain the DC result.
It is important to point
out that when we have the DC
result, we can only get to
correct results because we have
equal contributions from co
and counterrotating terms.
So that's sort of a
question one could ask.
You know, which mistake do you
do for the DC polarizability
when you do the rotating
wave approximation?
Well, you miss out
on exactly 50% of it.
Because both terms
become equally important.
I have deliberately focused
here on the calculation
of the dipole moment.
Because the dipole, I simply
calculated the dipole moment
as being proportion
to the electric field.
And the coefficient in front of
it is alpha the polarizability.
You may remember that
when we calculated
the effect of a
static electric field,
we looked for the DC Stark shift
for the shift of energy levels.
We can now discuss also
the AC Stark shift.
Which is a shift of the
energy levels due to the time
dependent field.
But I have to say you have
to be a little bit careful.
And sometimes when I looked
at equations like this,
there is a moment of confusion
what you want to actually,
what the question is.
Because the wave function is now
a time dependent wave function.
It's a driven system.
It's no longer your time
independent Schroedinger
equation and you
are asked, what is
the shift in the
value of eigenvalues?
So the AC Stark
shift here is now
given by the frequency
dependent polarizability.
And then, and I know some
textbooks do it right away.
And at the end of the
day, it may confuse you.
It uses an average of e square.
So in other words, if you
have an electric field which
is cosine omega t, and you
calculate what is the AC Stark
shift, you get
another factor of 1/2.
Because cosine square omega
t time average is 1/2.
So anyway, just
think about that.
It's one of those factors
of 1/2 which is confusing.
Will, you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So when
we take omega goes
to 0 from our previous
results, are we still justified
in neglecting the
transient term?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But why?
What will happen is
the transient term
is really a term which
has time dependence.
And even if omega is 0,
just the step function
of switching it on
creates an oscillation
in the atom at a frequency
which is omega excited
state minus omega ground state.
You may think
about it like this.
I give you more the
intuitive answer.
Take an atoms and put
it in electric field.
If you gradually switch
on the electric field,
you create a dipole moment
by mixing at 0 frequency
a p state into the s state.
And that displaces the
electron from the origin.
But if you suddenly switch
on the electric field,
you actually create a
response of the atoms which
has a beat node between the
excitation frequency of the p
state and the excitation
frequency of the s state.
And what you regard is the
DC response of the atom
is everything except
for this transient term.
However, and this tells
you maybe something
about the different formulas
in quantum mechanics
when we talked about the
time independent perturbation
theory.
We never worried
about the switch
on because we just did time
independent perturbation theory
and we sort of assumed that the
perturbation term had already
existed from the
beginning of the universe.
So it's not that we
excluded the term.
We formulated the
theory in such a way
that the term just
didn't appear.
But if you switch on a DC
field, you should actually
if you want an
accurate description,
do time dependent
perturbation theory,
you get the transient
term even for DC field.
And then you discuss
it away the way I did.
OK, so if you want, these
are the textbook results.
We could stop here.
But I want to add three
points to the discussion.
You can also see at
this point, we really
understand that AC
Stark shift theory
as you find it in generic
quantum mechanics textbooks.
And now I want to give
you a little bit of sort
of extra insight based on my
knowledge of atomic physics.
So there are three points I
would like to discuss here.
The first one is the relation
to the dressed-atom picture.
The second one is I want
to parametrize the results
for the polarizability using
the concept of oscillator
strengths.
And thirdly, I want
to tell you how
you can, already at this point,
take our result for the AC
polarizability and calculate
how do atoms absorb light
and what is the dispersive
phase shift which atoms generate
when they're exposed to light.
Or in other words,
I want to show you
that based on this
simple result,
we have pretty much already
all the information we need
to understand how absorption
imaging and dispersive
imaging is done
in the laboratory.
So these are the
three directions
I would like to take it.
So let's start with number one.
The relation to
the dressed-atom.
So what I want to show you now
is that a result we obtained
in time dependent
perturbation theory,
we could've actually obtained
in time independent perturbation
theory by not using a
coherent electric field which
oscillates.
But just assuming that
they're stationary Fock states
of photons.
And this is actually the
dressed-atom picture.
I know I'm throwing now a
lot of sort of lingo at you.
It's actually
very, very trivial.
But I want to show you that you
have a result where if you just
open your eyes, you see actually
the dressed-atom shining
through.
So what we had is we had
an energy shift here.
Which was let me just
summarize what we have derived.
Was this result with
a polarizability
which we derived.
And let me rewrite the
results from above.
So this is why I made the
remark about the averaging
of the electric field.
If you combine it
with, as you will see,
Rabi frequencies and
dressed-atom picture,
you'll need the amplitude
of the electric field.
And formulated in the amplitude
of the electric field,
you have a one quarter.
And this is not a mistake.
And you can really trace
it down to the time
average of the cosine term.
OK, so this is now-- I'm really
copying from the previous page.
We had the difference frequency
between state 1 and state 2.
So I'm simply assuming
that we couple two states.
Now an s and p
state, If you want.
We have a matrix
element which is
the matrix element of
the position operator,
z, between state 1
and state 2 squared.
We have an energy denominator
which was this one.
And we have-- so I'm just
rewriting the previous result.
But now I usually
hate matrix elements
when they appear in an equation.
I mean, who knows
matrix elements.
What is the relevant
thing when we
couple two different states
is the Rabi frequency.
Frequency units is what we want.
So, therefore, I have
prepared the formula
that I can take
the matrix element
with the electric field.
And this is nothing else than
the Rabi frequency squared.
Or actually, one is
measured as energy units.
The other is frequency units.
So there is an h bar square.
So, therefore, I have
now written this result
in what I think is a more
physically insightful way
by explicitly identifying
the Rabi frequency which
couples ground and
excited states.
And I also want
to separate, want
to introduce the
detuning of the time
dependent oscillating
electric field from resonance.
And then I obtain this result.
Doesn't it look so much simpler
than what we had before?
And it has a lot of
physics we can discuss now.
One over delta is sort
of like an AC Stark
effect in one limit.
It's a far-off resonant case of
an optical trapping potential.
So this formula has
a lot of insight
which I want to provide now.
The second part I give you the
name and the interpretation
will become obvious in a moment.
Is the important
Bloch-Siegert shift.
It is the AC Stark shift due
to the counterrotating term.
So what I'm motivating here
is just don't get confused.
What I write down
is very simple.
And I sometimes use advanced
language for those of you
who have heard those buzz words.
But what I really mean
is what I want to discuss
and you to follow are the
simple steps we do here.
So anyway, what
I've just done is
I've rewritten the result
from the previous page
by just introducing
what I suggest
as more physically
appealing symbols.
And now I want to remind you
that this result for the AC
Stark effect doesn't it look
very similar not to a result,
to the standard result of
time independent perturbation
theory?
And, of course, you
remember that in time
independent
perturbation theory, you
get an energy shift which is
the square of a matrix element
divided by detuning.
So it seems when we inspect
our result for the AC Stark
effect which came from time
dependent perturbation theory,
that this result here has
actually-- if we map it
on time independent perturbation
theory, it has two terms.
Both coupled by
the Rabi frequency.
But one has a detuning of delta.
And the other has a detuning
of minus 2 omega, minus delta.
So it seems that the result
for the AC Stark shift
can be completely understood
by a mixture of not one,
but two different states
with different detunings.
And this is exactly
what we will do
in 8.422 in the
dressed-atom picture
when we have quantized
the electromagnetic field.
In other words, we have photons.
Because then what we
have is the following.
We have the ground state
with n photons, n gamma.
Well, there are sort of
n quanta in the system.
n photons.
But what we can do is we can now
have one quantum of excitation
with the atom.
And n minus 1 photon.
So it's almost like
absorbing a photon.
And this state has
a detuning of delta.
But then we can also
consider an excited state.
In other words, here, we
connect to the excited state
by absorbing a photon.
But we can also, we talk
about it more later,
we can also connect
to the excited state
by emitting a photon.
So this state has now not
one quantum of excitation,
there's three quanta
of excitation.
One in the atom and
two in the photon.
So, therefore, its detuning
is now much, much larger.
Actually, if we're on
resonant, the detuning
would be just 2 omega.
But if you are detuned,
there is the delta.
So in other words,
we can just say
if it would do
time independent--
I'm not doing it here.
And I leave kind
of all the beauty
to when we discuss the
dressed-atom picture
in its full-fledged version.
But all I'm telling you is that
the result for the AC Stark
shift looks like type
independent perturbation theory
with those two detunings.
And I'm now offering you the
physical picture behind it
by saying, look, when we
have the ground state with n
photons, and we have
those two other states,
they have exactly the detuning
which our results suggests.
And yes, indeed, if you look at
the many folds for those three
states and we would simply do
time independent perturbation
theory, we would find exactly
the same frequency shifts,
the AC Stark shift
as we just obtained
in a time dependent picture.
So in other words, what
I'm telling you is there
are two ways to obtain
the AC Stark shift.
One is you do time dependent
perturbation theory assuming
oscillating electric field.
And that would mean in
the quantized language
you assume the electromagnetic
field is in a coherent state.
Alternatively, you can
quantize the electric field
and introduce Fock states.
And then because Fock
states are type independent,
then these are the eigenstates
of the electromagnetic field
in a cavity.
And now you obtain the
same atomic level shift
in time independent
perturbation theory.
So in other words, we can
have photon number states.
And do time independent
perturbation theory.
Or alternatively, we can use a
semi-classical electric field.
Which means we have a
classical electric field.
And then we can treat
it in time dependent.
All the textbooks generally
use the latter approach.
Because it uses a same
classical electric field.
But I can tell you, I strongly
prefer the first approach.
Because in the
first approach, you
have no problems whatsoever.
What is the time
dependent wave function?
What is an energy level shift
when you have a driven system?
In a time independent
way, everything just
is simple and right
there in a simple way.
But it's two different
physical regimes.
Questions?
OK, second point of
discussion is the concept
of the oscillator strengths.
So what I'm teaching in
the next five minutes
is so old-fashioned
that I sometimes
wonder should I still
teach it or not.
On the other hand, you find
it in all the textbooks.
You also want to understand
a little bit the tradition.
And at least I'm giving
you some motivation
to learn about it that if
I parametrize the matrix
element with an
oscillators strength.
And most of your atoms,
most of the alkali atoms
have an oscillator
strength for the s
to p transition for the D-lines.
Which is unity.
You can actually write down
what is the matrix element.
What is the spontaneous lifetime
of your atom without knowing
anything about atomic structure.
Just memorizing that f equals
1, the oscillator strength
is 1 is pretty much all you
have to know about your atom.
And the rest, the only
other thing you have to know
is what is the resonant
frequency of your laser?
780 nanometer?
589 nanometer?
671 nanometer?
So the modern motivation for
this old-fashioned concept
is for simple atoms where
the oscillator strength
is close to 1, this is
probably the parametrization
you want to use
because you can forget
about the atomic structure.
So but the derivation
would go as follows.
I want to compare our result.
How an atom responds
to an electric field.
I want to compare this
result to the result
of a classical oscillator.
So compare our result
for the AC polarizability
to a classical
harmonic oscillator.
So I assume this classical
harmonic oscillator
has a charge, a mass
term, and a frequency.
And both the atom and the
classical harmonic oscillator
are driven by the time
dependent electric field.
Which we have already
parametrized by cosine omega t.
OK.
If you look at the classical
harmonic oscillator,
you find that the--
you drive it at omega
and ask what is it time
dependent dipole moment?
It's driven by the cosine term.
And what I mean, of
course, is dipole moment
of a classical
harmonic oscillator
is nothing else than
charge times displacement.
And, well, if you
spend one minute
and solve the equation for the
driven harmonic oscillator,
you find that the response,
the amplitude, the steady state
amplitude, [? zk ?] of
the harmonic oscillator
is cosine omega t.
Times a prefactor which
I'm writing down now.
There is this resonant behavior.
So that's the response of the
classical harmonic oscillator.
And yeah.
So this is just classical
harmonic oscillator physics.
And I now want to
define a quantity which
I call the oscillator
strength of the atom.
So I'm just jumping now from the
harmonic oscillator to the atom
and then I combine a the two.
And the oscillator
strength is nothing else
than a parametrization
of the matrix element
with between different states.
But it's dimensionless.
And it's made dimensionless
by using the mass.
By using h-bar.
And by using the
transition frequency.
So the atomic-- let me just
make sure we take care of it.
This is the result for the
classical harmonic oscillator.
And this is now the
result for the atom
that we have found already they
the result for the atom before.
And now I'm rewriting
it simply by expressing
the matrix element square
by the oscillator strength.
And this here is just
another expression
for the polarizability alpha.
Well, let's now
compare the result
of a quantum mechanical
atom exactly described
by time dependent
perturbation theory
to the result of a classical
harmonic oscillator.
The frequency
structure is the same.
So if I would know say
we have an ensemble
of harmonic oscillators,
and the harmonic oscillators
may have different frequencies
and different charges.
Then I have made those
formulas exactly equal.
And I can now formulate
that the atom reacts
to an electric field to time
dependent electric field.
Exactly as an ensemble
of classical oscillators
with effective charge.
If I would say I have an
ensemble of oscillators
with effective charge,
then the response
of the atom and the
response of the ensemble
of classical oscillators
is absolutely identical.
So the atom response is a
set classical oscillators
with an effective charge
which is given here.
So, therefore, you
don't have to go further
if you want to have any
intuition how an atom reacts
to light.
The classical
harmonic oscillator
is not an approximation.
It is exact.
So that result is
relevant because it
allows us to clearly formulate
the classical correspondence.
The second thing is
as you can easily
show with basic
commutator algebra,
there is the Thomas
Kuhn sum rule
which is discussed in all
texts in quantum physics
which says that the sum over
all oscillator strengths is 1.
So, therefore, we know
if we have transitions
from the ground state
to different states,
the sum of all the oscillator
strengths to all the states
can only be 1.
And another advantage of the
formulation with oscillator
strength is that it is
a dimensionless unit.
It's a dimensionless
parameter which tells us
how the atom corresponds to an
external electromagnetic field.
I just need two or
three more minutes
to show you what that means.
If you have hydrogen,
the 1s to 2p transition
is the strongest transition.
And it has a matrix
element which
corresponds to an oscillator
strength of about 0.4.
So the rest comes from
more highly excited states.
However, for alkali atoms, the
D-line, the s to p transition
has an oscillator strength.
I didn't write down
the second digit,
but it's with excellent
approximation, 1.98
or something.
So not just qualitatively,
almost quantitatively,
you capture the response from
the atom by saying f equals 1.
So if you use for the
alkali atoms f equals 1,
then simply the transition
frequency of the D-line
gives you the
polarizability alpha.
And as we will see later,
because we haven't introduced
it is, but it will also give you
gamma the natural line beats.
Because all the coupling to
the electromagnetic field
to an external field is
really captured by saying what
the matrix element is.
And f equals 1 is
nothing else than saying
the matrix element
is such and such.
And, indeed, if I now use the
definition of the oscillator
strength in reverse,
the matrix element
between two transitions,
between two states
is the matrix element squared
is the oscillator length
times one half.
And if you just go back
and look at the formula,
you find that this
is now dimensionless.
So we need now because the left
hand side is the length square,
we need two lengths.
One is the Compton wave length
which is h-bar over 2 times
the mass of the electron.
And lambda bar is the
transition wave lengths,
lambda divided by 2 pi.
So, therefore, I haven't found
it anywhere in textbooks,
but this is my sort
of summary of this.
If you have a strong
transition, and strong
means that the oscillator
length is close to 1,
then the matrix element
for the transition
is approximately
the geometric mean
of the Compton wave
length of the electron.
And the reduced wave lengths
of the resonant transition.
So now if you want
to know what is
the matrix element for
the d-line of rubidium,
take the wave length
of 780 nanometer.
Take the Compton wave
lengths of the electron
and you get an
accurate expression.
I know time is over.
Any questions?
All right.